[What skills do you think
are most important
for people to have for jobs
available 10 years from now?]
I think social skills include flexibility
and the ability to work
with a diverse group of people.
I think that's very important.
And I think communication skills --
learning to clearly communicate
where you are in your progress,
what your roadblocks are,
and understanding that that's okay.
"I'm having an issue, I need this help."
People need better communication skills,
because I think teams are more agile,
and when people come together,
you just have to learn to communicate.
I think communication
is a very important skill.
I think computer skills
are going to be something
people expect you to have.
Imagine going to work and you're like,
"Gee, you know, I can't type.
I can't use a keyboard."
Well, of course
you have to use a keyboard!
So, the ability to learn
computer languages,
to have some basic programming skills.
Even the designers in our group,
they program in Arduino.
The social scientists are programming
these visualization packages.
I think computer literacy,
programming literacy,
is going to be extremely important.
(Audio) Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions
and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie
to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about.
Or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions, participants,
or career paths for future videos.